it's like bad guys like you
I'd mess it up every time maybe you just
need a partner feeling chancy practice
this follow my lead
[Applause]
oh you got Pez and Men and the wasp this
film is not yet rated so how long have
you been Antonin again no uh I just sort
of happened like bad guys like you
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch for
back
like a person
[Music]
back to Pam I actually heard what
happened to you you opened up the
quantum realm that's when he's crazy
could be ghostly like walks through
walls to stuff
so Leo tech and now supposed to take
over the world or whatever who would
have believed that in your hour of need
you would turn the house at me bleep Rob
do you do you remember that's us feeling
chess we practiced this oath the deal
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense you go low I'll
go high I have wings why would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you two
are finished comparing sizes 65
[Music]
you